hello everyone and welcome to Round
seven of the 2020 Gibraltar Masters it's
a one cow one of the candidates of the
2020 candidates tournament against
pregnant anthem in the previous round
the program under defeated a Veselin
Topalov in that brilliant well sort of
miniature 33 moves in modern chess can
be considered a miniature and now he
advances to the board one where he faces
Ivanka that with the black pieces so
it's it's really it's really an exciting
game so I do hope you enjoy it now
without further ado let's check it out
and we also do have a nice photo of the
match up there it is courtesy of the
photo total of official photographer of
the Gibraltar chess masters Nikki Riga
there you have it among how pregnant
under you can see that the time on the
clock still still hasn't started ticking
an hour and 40 minutes for both of them
Ivanka which is what appears to be a
carton of milk and pregnant and for a
moment with it without any refreshments
so let's check out the game one cow
opens with c4 the English is on the
board with a five by pregnant on de
nights the c3 Knight to f6 Knight f3 and
Knight to c6 the four nights of the
English we have III and Bishop to b4 we
have Queen to c2 in the now Bishop
captures and c3b captures this is the
the main line and now d6 and now
although d4 seems like a perfectly
reasonable move to play here
you don't wanted this pawn to remain
backwards this this hasn't been
attempted since 1984 and even then it
didn't really yield any results so today
if or is the main move which is what
about how plays with castles by pregnant
Wanda and the now g3 preparing to en get
to the Y squared Bishop and now Knight
to d7
we have Bush up the g2 and the noun
tonight the c5 since of white no longer
has a beep on you don't have to worry
about this night being kicked away it's
gonna be it's gonna be an excellent
piece here we have nights the age for
white a black might be preparing f5 with
the bishop nicely supports it also the
Queen from c2 supports it so night to h5
not sorry I mean the the Queen and
Knight will now prevent the idea for
five from being
we have a six preparing b5 and now
castles with b5 and here there is a
their argument where C capture some beef
I was played but here just the d4 we
have eke a person B for C CAP for Sandy
for a nightcap for Sundy for so pregnant
that wins upon but this is a line that's
a played with upon sacrifice but it has
been played only once Hilda Tyrolean
played against Peter Svidler in 2015
Russian championship and the game ended
in a draw here as fielder's opponent
played Queen to d2 but here one among
how or switches the Queen to b2 and it
is as a move 14 that we have a
completely new game so it this is what
basically where the game starts brago is
up upon but among how prepared something
obviously so what do you do here you
have to do something about the knight as
it's under attack so you could move it
back to c6 you could go back to maybe e6
so the thing is if you go back to east 6
then of course II five opens up this
discovery towards the rook then there
should be seven bishops get traded
captures captures and now CB 5 but here
you could go D captures an e5 and we
could just trade off everything Queen
captures Knight to d6 goes after the
pawn pawn captures rook captures and we
get this position where it's well White
has a past a pawn black has a past C
pawn material is equal however due to
the g3 move and white not having a light
square bishop black is a little bit to
be preferred here so after Queen B to
Prague or decides for Knight back to c6
instead with E 5 now again opening up
this discovery the knight is now under
attack Bishop to d7 defending and now he
captures and e6 we have seek a person d6
and only now Queen to d2 threatening to
win back this d6 pawn and here well you
could defend it with Queen to c7 this
would bring the Queen a bit too much
away from the Kings side then you could
just vote for example captures captures
Bishop b2 and you might have some
problems defending on the King side
knight can come to f5 you could maybe
force this trade and well probably
doesn't like this so after Queen d2 we
have worked
eight instead and now comes C capture
son b5 and now again you could go for
pawn captures and Queen captures and
these six however probably sites for
Knight to e5
he will give back some material but
again a lot of activity so B captures an
a6 and now Bishop to b5 attacking the
rook now threatening to win back the
pawn this way but now rook to d1 and now
okay you could capture on a6 Queen
captures and b6 and the game continues
but now it's different than that line
since the black no longer has a path C
pawn and white does have a fast a pawn
so not not something you want to do so
instead Bishop a4 pushes the wrong house
rogue back rook to e1 and now Knight C
to D three attacks the rook once again
rook F the roof to f1 and now rook the
seat do so and now Prague was the one
who's down upon but he's the one with
all the activity if you go Queen d1 to
try and sort up in the rook as the
bishop is undefended just Queen a5 now
the bishop is defended and all sorts of
nasty discoveries become possible so
after rook to c2 we have Quinta III and
now Knight back to c5 now threatening to
capture the a6 pawn but we have a seven
by one cow and Bishop to c6 now blocking
the light square Bishop with Bishop
captures and Knight captures and now
Queen to f3 again attacking the knight
on c6 Knight back to d4 attacking the
Queen and now Queen d5 again putting
pressure on the night we have night
Stewie to check by Prabhu King to g2 and
now Knight to c3 again going for an
attack to the Queen Queen to a5 is also
a possibility since now now you can you
can also guard the Queen squared this
way but for example you get Knight to f5
now Queen captures an a7 and now Bishop
to e3 and it's still playable but the
white doesn't really have any problems
here so instead of this Quinta if I move
Prager goes for Knight to c3 again
pressures the Queen Queen back to f3 and
the now Queen to a8 offering a queen
trade and here comes just a beautiful
beautiful
my uncle he plays Knight to f5 and
Knight to f5 means that if you trade
Queens here for example Queen captures
King captures and let's say now you want
to win back the pawn you will not be
able to do two knights to d4 and now the
rook is trapped well almost you have to
trade on a two rook captures rook
captures Knight captures and now you get
tonight
the b5 the defending the PO sorry nice
to be 5 defending the pawn and then now
after black goes after it night before
you get Bishop to e3 Knight to c6 now
finally ready to pick up the a7 point
but now rook to d1 and this is all
pretty much very very forced after
Knight captures an a7 Knight captures
rook captures you will capture here and
there is no defense against theirs
either mate or you lose the knight or
you move the knight for example then you
lose the rook so this this Knight to f5
is a super sneaky move by one cow which
means that if the Queen's are traded
Prague will not be able to win back the
a7 point and he's gonna be stuck
defending it for quite some time if it
will be possible at all so instead Prado
goes after the pawn queen characters on
a 7 ok he still has his d6 pawn and he
will have to deal with Monkhouse past
passed a to pawn and here again we reach
a very interesting position what do you
play here I'm not gonna ask you to pause
the video because this is a super
disgusting engine line so there is no
point in it points into me asking you to
do it but here among how played Bishop
to f4 he adds another attacker to the d6
pawn and also in the future he wants to
play a three and he wants the bishop to
guarded the pawn on a3 however there was
Bishop to h6 here but it's so difficult
to calculate this not if you capture if
you capture its mate right away that's
that's not a problem the problem is
after Bishop to h6 after knights the e6
what do you play here well the point is
rook eight to c1 you go after the rook
of course the rule cannot capture
because the knight hangs so rook
captures rook captures and mountain
Knight captures in a - but now rook the
c4 getting ready to bring the rook over
to g4 and now after Queen to a8 offering
Queen trade well basically forcing a
queen trade now you play Knight captures
and g7 you get Queen captures on f3 King
captures on f3 Knight captures and g7
and now look to G for threatening to win
the night here and after any move you
play that really matter Knight captures
now you capture the pawn King h8 and now
you can capture on h7 open up a
discovery towards the rook and now you
tray down into into this winning endgame
it's not the just that you're up upon
but it's just that your pawn structure
is much much better and these pawns are
all messed up so it would be winning but
calculating all of this from here not
don't see it happening
so Bishop the f4 by monk how it's move
31 and they both I need need to reach
time control we have Knights the e6 now
there's no point in trying trying to
defend this guy here so nice to these
Knights the e6 and now Bishop captures
and d6 it's remarkable how long long how
left this pawn alive because at any
point he could have captured it but then
he just allows the black to start
activating even the other Brookwood rook
to da and he left it for for this moment
so Bishop captures and b6 Knight to g5
attacking the Queen and now Queen to c6
saying you cannot move the knight
otherwise you're gonna lose the rook and
you cannot capture because well then the
knight would hang of course so Queen the
a8 offering the Queen trade and only now
uncle trades we have captures rook
captures an a8 and only now a3 from
where the bishop guards the pawn so move
35 and well monk how is now up a past a
pawn so Knight g4 going after the bishop
here now rook a to C 1 going after the
undefended rook rook captures rook
captures and here Prague played g6 so
what do you play here it's uh it's a
it's a very interesting move g6 because
if you go for the just Knight characters
you're not characters here and rook
captures here sort of defending and
seemingly trading down into any equal
endgame it's actually losing do tonight
b5 the rook is under attack after we
moved the rook you're going to lose the
night and of course if you capture it's
just a nice background mate so here
pregnant manda has to play something g6
kicks away tonight also create some
breathing room for the king but now feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the cleanest way for among how to
continue this game while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on being an excellent excellent
calculator of the lines in in the end
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's night eastern
check now the point is a pregnant
underplayed king to f8 but king to g7 or
is also worth considering however after
Bishop e5 check there's a double attack
on the night you could go back now after
the night but now after Bishop captures
on c3 you cannot play keen capture since
the King characters on e7 because of
rook to e1 and you just lose a piece for
example f5 just f3 wins the night here
so what you would have to do after
Bishop captures on c3 is king captures
and e7 sorry not King captures and e70
would have to recapture Knight captures
and c3 but now
white always has this at sufficient
Zhuge in-betweener
night the captures and on g6 you would
have to capture as this with check and
then now our characters and c3 and now
you're in a rockin game where your four
points against do which is a very very
much winning for white so after this 97
check partner and I said okay I have to
go you know face the bishop and the now
comes Knight captures and g6 with a
double check from the knight and the
bishop King g7 and now Knight to h4
saying that okay now I'm up I'm up to
two pawns if you capture here I'm just
gonna capture and c3 but there really is
nothing better
so Knight captures we have rook captures
and not nice to be 5 going after the
rook and the pawn but now rook the c6
so you will lose this pawn and you will
only be up one point but our problem is
the the King will not be able to gain
any activity so Knight captures on a3
you have to get rid of the passed pawn
now Knight f5 pushing the King further
back King g8 and the now rook the c7 now
with threats of just the Knights to h6
check and then you're just losing Oh
the material so look the f8 at least you
you will not be able to win the pawn
here
so King f3 among cow starts activating
his skin we ignite the b1 now comes King
III by preventing night study - so now
rook e8 check but now King to f4 this
was a nice little idea how to gain a
temple nice the d2 by Prague and now f3
taking away the e4 square from blacks
pieces look back to f8 you still have to
keep an eye on the f7 pawn now h4 we
have Quinta a trade by Prague now h5 we
have King to g8 Prague we just has to
wait and see what white will do g4 and
now comes King to h8 and g5 with King to
g8 and here Knight to h6 with check now
the problem is like I said you can't go
back because then just rope captures so
you have to keep an eye on the pawn king
g7 was played now Kim G for you how you
make room to start pushing the other
pawn as well we had Knights to f1 and
then now Knight to f5 with check King
back to g8 and here evanka played the
the sneakiest move possible he played
rook to d7 and it was in this position
that a pregnant resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
rook d7 with the idea that now you don't
have you cannot just start checking the
the king that's the problem because
after let's say Knight H to check you
can just attack the knight and then
after Knight goes back night f1 check
King f2 now you don't have an ID -
because the route covers that you have
to go back and then just King G 2 wins
the night so that's why I wrote the d7
such a super sneaky move so your other
option after work to the seventh would
be to not do anything with the night to
just continue playing King guillotine g8
but then you just wait for the
inevitable f4 King g8 night at 6 sure
King g7 now f5 is coming okay you do
have some checks 93 checking a four
night g2 checking g3 Knights the e3 but
now f6 with check King - a trait and the
now finally Knight captures on f7 with
the check King to g8 now you go back
night h6 check King - a trade and the
now you of course played
sex with rook captures on h7 being the
threat of checkmate and there's really
not much you can do here captures
captures and it doesn't really matter if
Roe captures you're just getting
checkmate it if you try something else
there's nothing else to try you could
try something like totally silly like
something like this captures captures
and maybe maybe not gee foreign captors
to try and get a stalemate but of course
of course white would not capture any of
these pieces but you know it never hurts
to try
it hasn't been been done before but yeah
so after rook to d7 pregnant and
resigned and Ivanka remains in first
place of the Gibraltar Masters 2020 so
another another very impressive game
proton on the plate in great style first
he was given points for activity then he
returned material to gain met Eva T
himself and then in all of this chaos
among how just prevailed as he is one of
the candidates of the 2020 candidates
tournament but yeah there are I've seen
there are a lot more games and thank you
all for suggesting them I will continue
covering them so you know we'll we'll
see more games even by pregnant himself
and well all the arrogance that you
suggest that I will try to cover as many
as possible so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Nicolas Ben's Salazar like Ally re-bend
papel Russell Lloyd and David Kaiser who
is not from Germany I think you ought to
really appreciate it as usual you can
check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
2020 Gibraltar masters continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and of course when we get the
opportunity continuing the Paul Morphy
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day